our next speaker
is an expert burrito wrapper
having wrapped over 10 000 burritos
please welcome Caitlin thank you all so
much for having me I'm Caitlin huden I'm
a data scientist at figma and I'm here
today to talk about making decisions
with data I think this is a topic that's
probably near and dear to a lot of our
hearts and so I'm going to go a little
bit through a framework that I've used
that's helped to guide my work
and we'll start with the why here oh
this is getting cut off a little bit let
me uh
if I can resize
did that update let's see
Ah that's okay
um so we're going to start with an
intake form which actually came from
this tweet or was referenced in this
tweet and so in this tweet I was asking
a question like which is more important
to stakeholders getting an answer
quickly or getting an accurate answer
and this came from a form that we used
to start to clarify expectations around
analysis because we found that we were
getting a lot of requests for analysis
but it wasn't very clear like how the
analysis would be used like what was the
decision that people were trying to make
and how could we be most helpful and so
this form helped us to work with
stakeholders in order to like set the
table for those conversations
a couple of questions that were on the
Forum the first one was describe your
request like let us know what is it that
you're trying to accomplish and then
later on in the Forum there was what
decision will you make or action will
you take with this data and one of the
things that we started to realize
is that the data requests didn't match
the decisions that people were trying to
make and so they would ask for something
very specific that was answering a
question that was like part of what they
were trying to get at but in further
conversation we would find that maybe
there was like another piece of data or
another type of analysis that could be
more helpful for them for making the
decisions and so we found that these
conversations were really the thing that
were most important and so figuring out
how to guide those conversations would
be really valuable for our team both
like the data team and cross-functional
people so that we could come to
conclusions like a little bit faster and
better
so we got really good at asking these
questions to gather some of the context
and the framework that I've put together
here is taking years of asking those
kinds of questions over and over again
and putting it into a five-step
framework that we use to define the
decision to find the data that we need
to make the decision and then use data
to help inform the decision
and so you can summarize it a little bit
like this we're starting with the
decision that we want to make and
getting really clear on that so that we
can put together like analysis or data
in order to support it and then we
Circle back to the decision and make
sure that we're able to actually
complete a decision with the data that
we have
so the first step in the framework is to
define the decision this sounds really
straightforward but I think sometimes
we'll get an ask and it won't be very
clear like is the decision that we're
trying to decide whether to ship or not
is the decision that we're trying to
figure out if we should run a test on
something is the decision something else
and so getting really clear on like what
the decision is that you're trying to
make is the first step towards being
able to use data to inform it
so that's the first question what is the
decision that you want to make really
Frame It Up get everyone on the same
page with what it is that you're trying
to decide
the next part to understanding the
decision is understanding what are your
options and so maybe your options are
that you ship something or you don't
chip something maybe your options are
tied to a timeline or something else
getting clear on like what are the
different options and how might data
inform those options will help you when
you go to do an analysis because you'll
understand the things that you're trying
to optimize for
which leads into the next one which is
what is your goal so if you're making a
decision you probably have a goal in
mind or a thing that you're trying to
optimize for or work with stakeholders
to optimize for and so getting everyone
clear on what the goal is can be really
helpful I've sometimes walked into these
situations where two different
stakeholders are sort of asking for data
science to help with something and they
have goals that are aligned but maybe
not exactly the same and so
understanding what a clear goal could be
will help you to inform your analysis
another one is what does a good outcome
look like and so if we're thinking about
an analysis maybe a good outcome is
making a decision very directly maybe a
good outcome is reducing uncertainty but
understanding what will be the most
helpful thing that you could bring with
an analysis will ensure that the work
that you do provides value to your team
alternatively it's also really helpful
to know if there are outcomes that would
be considered bad or unacceptable or
must be avoided and so if there's a
particular outcome where your analysis
is showing you that you might be heading
in like a direction that is bad that
gives you the opportunity to come back
to the table and say maybe we should
reframe this maybe we should consider
this other option but understanding what
kind of outcomes people are hoping for I
think is really helpful for finding
early signs that may be confirming that
in the data
so once we've defined the decision to be
made itself and we're able to answer all
of these questions we also want to be
able to Define some of the context and
constraints I find that some of the best
decisions come from combining data with
um the context that we have like
throughout a business so we might know
data says this there might be times
where there are things that like support
that in other parts of the business
maybe there's ux research that also kind
of combines with the data or maybe there
are things that we know in the business
that might contradict the data or might
be things that we need to consider
alongside the data when making a
decision and so having an idea of what
those things are before you do an
analysis is really helpful so that you
can start to talk to those people you
can start to understand those worlds you
can make a decision that's a lot more
holistic and also inform your data
analysis so that it's covering the parts
that you don't already know as a
business
so some questions you can ask here do
you have a deadline like is there a date
at which this analysis would no longer
be helpful this is a mistake I've made
in the past like taking too long to do
an analysis because I didn't realize
that there was like a go or no-go date
that's actually really important to hit
and so understanding if there is a
deadline Associated it with it is great
also what happens if you don't meet that
deadline like are there very severe
consequences an example of this is like
maybe you have a user conference and
you're trying to get something out ahead
of the user conference and so if you
don't meet that deadline you might be
waiting like another year for such a big
stage to like do a release or put
something forward or maybe there are
alternatives that you can talk about if
you don't hit that deadline that are
worth knowing ahead of time so all of
this again is just to like inform the
data work that you're going to do to
help make data informed decisions
knowing whether your decision is
reversible is really helpful so I've
seen this referred to as like a one-way
door or a two-way door and so a one-way
door is a decision that you are not
going to reverse sometimes pricing can
fall into this category and so knowing
that up front when you're doing the
analysis can really help you to like
frame those questions there are times
where if your decision is reversible and
if it's something you could like a B
test pretty quickly and roll back maybe
you don't need to do the level of rigor
that you might want to do for something
that you absolutely cannot walk back and
need to be very sure about and so
understanding more about the decision
and what happens if things kind of go
awry ahead of time is really helpful
what are your other practical
constraints like for the decision or for
the process to make it I've been in
rooms sometimes where I've done an
entire analysis only to find out that
there was like an additional stakeholder
who really should have been in the room
from the beginning who have really
important perspective that maybe upended
the impact or the intended impact of the
analysis so once they entered the room
their insights were so valuable and had
so much business context that it
completely shifted the lens in which we
could use the data work that I had done
and so starting to learn about those
things ahead of time so everyone could
get on the same team and build alignment
before you even get to data analysis is
something that I found super duper
helpful
and so once you've cleared these two
sets of questions and so clarifying the
decision and then understanding the
context around it I feel like you
actually have basically what we asked
for in our intake form and hope to get
to at the end of that first conversation
which is understanding the thing that
you're going to do and how you can add
value so at this point hopefully you
have ideas about the kinds of data that
you could be pulling or working with in
order to make a good data informed
decision
so the next step is to determine the
data needed and so when we're thinking
about a decision that we'd like to make
I think it's really helpful to frame the
decision before we start talking about
the data needed to inform it because any
of those things above shifting could
change the kind of data that we're
looking at and what it is that we care
about or want to get out of it so a few
questions we can ask here
what information will help you to reduce
uncertainty and make a good decision and
so outlining the things that you're
uncertain about can be really helpful to
decide like where to focus your time and
energy in terms of doing data science or
doing analysis
um another thing I recommend is where
possible writing all of this down so
that you have a record of the decision
that you want to make how you think data
will support the decision when you
actually carry out an analysis you can
tie that into the additional context
around it and then even documenting like
what the decision was and having those
artifacts will help you and your team to
get better at decision making over time
because you'll be able to see past
examples of patterns of decisions that
you've had to make and so you can see
like patterns and the kinds of analysis
that were helpful or even patterns in
the kind of context that it's helpful to
gather but knowing what will help you to
reduce uncertainty is really important
to inform the work that you'll do
um we're getting into a few hypothetical
questions that I love to ask I find
these to be ways to shortcut the
analysis process and so all of these are
kind of putting things in front of
stakeholders and seeing how they react
to them and so one question I'd like to
ask is is there data that would
unequivocally tip the scale toward any
given option so if you saw that a
certain number was like at a certain
value would that automatically help you
to make a decision yes or no and if that
is the case that can save you a lot of
time in analysis because then you know
you can go check that thing first and if
it's not where it needs to be you can
continue doing all the work that you
need to do but also it's a good way to
kind of shortcut to the end
another one is if you're leaning in One
Direction what data would make you
change your mind and I really like
asking these things these two things
together
um because it's kind of like this turn
and confirm hypotheses like if we have
this hypothesis and if there's one piece
of data or one level at which we would
say like ah I don't know if we should
make a decision like choosing a we
should probably look at b a little bit
more I find that to be super helpful
and then my favorite thing to do is
hypothetically audition different data
values and so often stakeholders will
have a specific thing that they're
looking for and so what I'll do is say
like okay if you want conversion rate to
be you know 50 what if we find the
conversion rate is 75 or 95 or 25 how
would that change the way that we would
make a decision and being able to just
like hypothetically talk about that
ahead of time can set you up to do an
analysis so that you're taking like the
path of least resistance and getting to
consensus in an aligned way a lot faster
because you already know what you'll do
in these different what-if situations
this is something I took directly from a
b testing best practices where it's
really helpful to know ahead of time
like lock in your predictions and the
point at which you would turn something
on or would roll back an experience and
so of taking that and applying it to
decisions has been something that's been
really helpful for me
um oop this is a repeat slide reduce
uncertainty and make good decisions
the next thing to do is to collect and
interpret data and so I think for a lot
of the people in this room we're
probably doing that work ourselves but
once we know what it is that we're
looking for and things that will be
helpful for us to get there it's time
for actually for us to actually go ahead
and like find data and start to work
with it I'm not going to speak to this
part as much because I think like this
is so subject dependent but a couple of
quick notes
it's really helpful to tailor tailor
your analysis or exploratory work
towards the questions that you've
defined as important in order to make
the decision and so answering those
questions clearly and documenting those
answers is a really good way that you
can see how your data helps to impact
decisions
and then if you're not going to be doing
the analysis yourself or even if doing
an analysis holistically requires you to
work with other stakeholders maybe even
those are like other data scientists in
different departments sharing as much
context as possible is something that
I've found to be very helpful I think we
all know like if we're doing an analysis
we're making tons of micro decisions
that's why data scientists are so good
at using data to inform decisions
because if we want to decide like should
I dig into this more is there a pattern
here we're doing this kind of
calculation all the time and so we know
how much context can help to inform
analysis and help a person to make the
correct trade-offs or the trade-offs
that are aligned to the way you're
thinking about a problem that's why I
think it's so important to actually like
share this pre-work with them if you're
going to get additional people like
working on the analysis portion of a
decision
and then finally make your decision I
think this sometimes gets left out
because it can be a less formal process
like often someone will read the results
and then go or no go and you might get a
message in slack but there's not always
a lot of documentation around this and I
found it to be super helpful to document
all of the pre-work all of the findings
alongside the actual decision that you
make and so that way when you're looking
back over your decisions you have a feel
for why you made them what was the
context and maybe what you might do
differently I know for me sometimes I'm
revisiting parts of the product that
someone else worked on like two years
ago and so the decisions that were made
two years ago might not be the same ones
that we would make today just given the
way that things change and so seeing the
decision that people were trying to make
the context around why understanding the
business context too can be really
helpful if you're looking back at like
old analysis to see what may or may not
inform your situation today
um so I wanted to talk about some
benefits of using a framework like this
for you and your team
starting with having a record of
decisions and how data supported them so
it's really useful to be able to look
back and see the role that data played
in decision making especially if you're
making decisions that follow a pattern
or similar to things that you've decided
in the past if you can look back and see
that historical context you're able to
understand a little bit more about like
why the decision happened and how data
helped to bring it there
you can also validate that your work
will be used before you build I really
liked the talk from yesterday about
answering product data questions and the
importance of on like reducing
uncertainty and figuring out the value
of the work before you take it on I
found this framework to be really
helpful for that because by talking to
stakeholders ahead of time I'm ensuring
that the work I'm doing is answering the
actual questions that will unlock the
uncertainty that they need in order to
like make a decision and do it
effectively with data
this also leads to higher quality more
data informed decisions because we're
combining data with the business process
we're not just doing an analysis handing
off the results and hoping that the
things that we found get implemented in
the best way this is about being
responsible for the work and being
responsible for the translation of data
into business context and how data can
actually help to make the decision and
so I find it really helpful to be in the
room and very involved in the
conversations that are happening right
up until the point of the decision so
that I can make sure to advocate for the
data answer any follow-up questions that
people have and really ensure that the
data is being used in the best way to
set the context and build a holistic
decision
um and then making decisions more
efficiently and effectively I think is
the best thing that this process has
brought to my work personally and so
being able to cut through some of the
rounds of like oh I kind of thought you
meant this or I pulled this thing which
might help you into inform this thing
this is able to shortcut some of those
cycles of doing work and so we all know
that like data science isn't something
where you prove one hypothesis and then
you're just done often questions but get
questions and even analyzes but get more
questions but being able to be on the
same page about what it is that we're
trying to accomplish has helped me to
more efficiently navigate those Loops
especially by proposing like
hypothetical end values and what we
might do in different situations gives
me a way to like Traverse that tree in
the most efficient way and then making
decisions effectively so as a team if
people get used to this kind of process
and used to answering the kinds of
questions around context that you'll
have when you're doing an analysis
they'll be able to better tailor their
requests and make the first process of
like defining the decision more
efficient because they have examples to
work from and they kind of know what it
is that you're going to ask them so over
time using this in an organization helps
to up level the per the people around
you so they understand the kinds of
considerations in data that you might
have some of the ways I've seen this
work are things like maybe we have
specific questions that we always ask
about our data like maybe we care about
paid users and free free users and maybe
we look at those populations separately
or maybe we have specific quarters or
times of the year where we might choose
to like include data or exclude data
from that time so if you find yourself
asking the same questions over and over
again I think putting that into a more
like formal conversation or putting it
into an artifact could be really helpful
for people to know that those questions
are coming and it just gives them a
little bit more pre-work to do that
makes your conversations a lot more
productive so you can just get to
alignment
and that's it
um so if you want to get in touch my
website is caitlinhuden.com and you can
find like a contact form there I'm also
online pretty much every platform at
Biana Posey and happy to chat there too
thank you